okay very excited to be here today to
talk to you about work
on the evolution of plant shapes using
these models that we've been hearing a
lot about this morning so I think there
was a good primer for the work that I'm
going to present here on many of the
talks that we saw today I'm gonna focus
on the biological questions and how
those models can be applied to a very
specific biological question I want to
start by just showing you this very
basic pattern of biodiversity the
distribution of organisms on earth
varies according to where you are and
what location you are this is a map
showing the number of vertebrate species
so the hot colors are the locations that
contain many species and you can see
that it varies by latitude meaning the
distance north or south of the Equator
so we see there are many more species in
the tropics
then there are contained in the
temperate environments in North America
and Asia one explanation for those
differences is that there are stark
climatic differences between locations
such that some locations can afford
the many higher numbers of species that
are located in others so this would be
just comparison to say the Saharan
desert and the tropics of Peru but there
are also locations where that seems to
be much more climatic similarity this
looks like a very lush forest in British
Columbia but there are still many fewer
species containing this forest than
there are in Peru this is a pattern that
we see across all taxa this is not just
specific to say plants or birds it's
across many varied groups of animals and
in particular it is true that plants
generally follow a latitudinal diversity
gradient so here I'm just showing you
the number of flowering tree species on
the x-axis and that number kind of bend
according to where you are in the earth
and you can see on this plot that there
are many more species contain than there
are outside of it but one component so
we have known this pattern for centuries
essentially and biologists have really
been vexed by it and we want to
understand why it exists and how it
is related to other aspects of
biodiversity that were interested in so
not all species are the same as saying
there this number of ecological
groupings in those locations so we want
to kind of tease apart the number of
species from the number of Ecology's one
example of the way that not all species
are ecologically unique there's an
example from bird's disaster ops genus
of birds a group of white eyes so this
is the white eye here down this image
and the image that I'm showing you on
over there is six different species of
white eyes and so to you know the lay
observer it might just look all like the
same bird right so what what's true is
that it's just because there are six
different species really we could call
these kind of the same ecology there's
six species but maybe one ecological
function and so we want to tease apart
these aspects of say shape from the
other taxonomic diversity that we've
described in museums for centuries so we
know that species that are similar in
shape and size perform a similar
ecological function which raises two
questions the first is how does shape
diversity
vary according to latitude we know that
the number of species changes according
to latitude and that have informs
another can deeper fundamental question
about evolutionary biology which is
whether species at different latitudes
have some sort of different ability to
carve up the ecological space in those
places so is it that tropical species
are really just able to become more
finely and specifically adapted towards
one ecological function and that's the
reason why we've jammed so many more
species in those locations than
otherwise so plant leaf shapes are
obviously very diverse and complex we've
certainly all walked around in a forest
and looked around and seen many
different shapes and sizes there's just
a schematic there of some of the
different shapes of leaves as they're in
particularly
species as they develop so there's
obviously also changes according to
development but there's also this very
basic pattern that's known in plant
shape according to latitude which is
that high latitude temperate locations
have more tooth leaves so the edges of
this leaf are called tooth and this
tropical leaf has what's called an
entire margin and so the absence of
tooth in tropical locations so
evolutionary biologists have been trying
to study this difference and we're kind
of interested in a next level of
complexity one that doesn't necessarily
involve just saying this is tooth this
is not but something more complex so
we've heard a lot this morning about the
kind of magic of computer vision and how
it might help us and reduce some of this
complexity to understand shape
differences so we focused our study on
ferns of the world for about 12,000
species of ferns distributed globally
here's two such examples two specimens
that are contained in the u.s. national
herbarium and there are two different
species I think it's fairly obvious that
they look very different and it's that
difference is very complex so it might
be difficult to measure the difference
between those two organisms except for
if we might use something like a
convolutional neural net to extract that
information the distribution of ferns of
the world follows of the kind of a
similar pattern to what we find among
other organisms there are many more
species contained in the tropics this is
actually just a quick estimate of the
number of species that might be located
in different places on earth using a
data set that we heard about this
morning called G Biff or the global
biodiversity information facility so I
took all of the occurrences that existed
on G before ferns and mapped them
according to where they were found these
are for all occurrences that had some
decimal lat and long we find that again
there are many more species contained in
the tropics
ferns are also highly diverse in both
size and shape so here are eight
specimens of eight different species we
can see that you know there's really a
lot of complexity here that we'd like to
understand but it's not so obvious how
we might get to that answer if not for
some large scale kind of method that
would help us kind of put all these
eight species in some sort of high
dimensional or low dimensional space
based on their differences which are
clearly very high dimensional so ferns
have been completely digitized at the
u.s. national barium we heard about the
digitization effort this morning I just
want to show you this is kind of what an
herbarium looks like it looks and almost
nothing like that normally that is just
when you want to get a really cool image
for everyone to look at normally it's
just a bunch of file cabinets that are
closed but they're flat specimens that
we can then digitize which is a really
useful way in which we've kind of moved
forward with this project so our
approach was to take all of the
specimens that are contained all the
digitized specimens that we could find
for ferns not only in the Smithsonian
but also on a larger kind of
international collaboration mostly
focused on North America called the
integrated digitized bio collections or
I dig bio so we took images from ID'd
bio as well as images from Smithsonian
to train three models the first model
was to identify the labeled especi me a
cording to the genus of the plant of the
fern on the image and we only we built
the kind of this as our simplest model
which is that we took general that had
at least 500 occurrences in our dataset
so we've kind of alluded to it all day
but it's more difficult to learn
features when you have fewer training
examples in this case we wanted there to
be at least 500 training examples for
each genus but we started to change that
up as we found that our original model
was incredibly accurate so we
to kind of test the limits of it we made
a model where there were fifty specimens
per genus so a lot of this is related to
where botanists have collected plants
around the world and how those
collections have been built so there's
somewhat of that bias in terms of you
know where the specimens are distributed
and which specimens we found but partly
rare specimens tend to come from places
that botanist don't visit very often and
might be unique so that's kind of why we
moved around like this so we built a
general model with 269 generate for
about 50 specimens and then ultimately a
1425 species model with at least 50
specimens per species so in each case
the the model gets more complex and it
would be more challenging for our model
to distinguish between the different
labels that we're going to give it so we
talked a little bit this morning about
confusion confusion matrices but this is
essentially how we validate the model
after we've trained it in the first case
we had hundreds of thousands of images
and we carved up our training set into
80% of those images that we would train
our data with and 20% of those images
which had never seen we're now going to
ask how good is it at giving the correct
label that we actually already know so
if we're given genus the actual genus a
we have some proportion of the labels
that the that the neural net then
generates for that genus and we can plot
those accordingly in that a row what you
want to see is that blue diagonal where
it would be a hundred percent of the
actual genus was predicted to be a at
the bottom but sometimes there is some
confusion it's true that the the model
is certainly not perfect and oftentimes
that confusion happens between things
that are closely related so in this case
we're looking at three genus from a
family of what's called the tree ferns
and there tend to be tended to be more
confusion say within this family than
outside of it but the model was
incredibly accurate overall at 97%
accuracy to identify the genus in our 86
genus model and that accuracy didn't
change too much I moved to the 269 genus
model and you can see that it was highly
accurate across that diagonal but it's
those boxes that contain families of
Jena where you see more confusion so
that's telling us that the model is
operating according to the biology the
biologists intuition it's not
accidentally making mistakes too widely
outside of the exact type of mistakes
that a less trained botanist might make
if they were making identifications in
the field or if they weren't using a
hand lens many of these general are
distinguished by traits that are
essentially not visible by the human eye
so it's pretty incredible in that way
that the machine is actually learning
patterns of differences that we don't
currently use to differentiate between
them so when we trained our model on
species if we remain it remained a
highly accurate model and some of the
inaccuracies were I think forgivable
first off I just am showing you two
plots these are kind of basic metrics
that you gather as you train a neural
network and we talked a little bit this
morning about epochs which are
individual periods where you cycle your
entire training data set through the
model and so the model is constantly
changing what we're doing is essentially
feeding images through this model it has
some prediction at the end and there's
an error with that prediction and we
want to modify the parameters in a way
that would reduce that error so that
error is the loss that you're seeing
here on the y-axis on this panel we want
that loss to be plummeting as we are
training the model and there's a loss
both based on the training data set and
on the validation training set on the
validation set and usually what you end
up with is that the training set has a
lower loss because it's starting to kind
of converge on specific things that it's
learning about those images so as soon
as that starts to
kind of Plateau you stopped raining but
we also have accuracy the accuracy is
both the exact max at match accuracy but
also the accuracy in the top five so in
this case I'm showing the exact match
accuracy which is about eighty one point
five percent for species but for the top
five predictions it gets the right
species in that top five about ninety
five point six percent of the time and
that is pretty incredible essentially a
lot of species are just differentiated
by by genetic markers so the actual
shape differences that the images are
going to be able to pick up on are
almost non-existent and so for the model
to get that level of accuracy I think is
a forgivable level of error so what is
this firm net using to make its
identifications here I'm showing you for
example images that were passed through
the network and then for activation Maps
essentially these are the pixels that
the neural net found most interesting
and most relevant to making a prediction
and the good thing is is that the heat
or the hot colors in these heat maps are
over top of the plant and not on the
label and not learning how to read the
label it's learning something about the
images we can also make some really cool
things called feature Maps essentially
what I'm gonna show you next is the
different output of specific layers in
our neural network and essentially what
we would be looking at is what the
filter might look like that would
activate for that layer of the model
earlier layers in these image
recognition models tend to look more
like shapes and patterns and high-level
layers tend to be kind of very specific
for making those final distinctions
between say species a or species B so
here are for example feature Maps there
are hundreds of layers in this model so
I can't show you
all of the feature maps but what how
they've built these is by randomly
populating an image with colors and then
optimizing that image so that it would
maximally activate that layer so yes
they look Technicolor than and more like
you know the 90s color palette of neon
but the colors don't matter very much
and that's I think a really important
part about our model is that it's not
activating by color the colors tend to
be very invariant the shapes are highly
variable and it's really more about
shape so you can see that later filter
maybe if you squint your eyes it looks a
little bit like a complex fern frond so
that's kind of getting towards our fern
shapes okay we saw a little bit about
why or how these models work to generate
from a very complex data input a very
low dimensional or single Dement
two-dimensional vector at the very end
and that vector the 1 by 496 vector
right before it gets to the 1 by 1425
vector which is actually the probability
that our image is within the 1425
different levels that 496 vector is the
one that we want to project in our you
map space like we saw earlier today with
the pix plot projections in this case
we're using a model that was
specifically trained to understand the
differences of species shapes for ferns
so we're not using the larger kind of
front end model from you know image net
or ResNet or something like that that's
pre trained we're using a model that's
trained on these things so we think
those feature embeddings at 496 vector
is actually a really useful vector not
for trying to understand the very
and say the label or this color ramp
because every one of these images has
that so the model should have basically
kind of stopped learning about those so
we take those and we project them into a
two-dimensional space and we can get our
shape space for firms so in this case
what we're looking at is a
two-dimensional projection of each point
is representative of one of those images
just like we saw earlier today with the
cool visualizations that pics plot
generated we could look at this image
and kind of drill in and look at each
individual specimen and where it's
positioned within this shape space so
here I've just thrown up two example
images and we see that they look quite
different from one another there is
actually a Euclidean distance that that
is preserved in this projection so we
can measure the distance between them as
some aspect of their shape dissimilarity
or similarity and we can then use that
to understand this latitudinal diversity
gradient so here I'm actually now just
dividing the world instead of looking at
latitude neural differences continuously
I've just divided the world in the four
unique kind of groupings tropical
climates Mountain desert climates
temperate climates should the blue ones
and the dark blue is the polar climates
and now I'm just gonna label our shape
space based on whether or not our ferns
fell into these categories and lo and
behold there's definitely some
clustering related to where those ferns
are evolving where they're operating
ecologically and where they are in our
shape dimensions you can see that
there's kind of a cluster of temperate
things it's kind of surrounds this
that's maybe other cluster of tropical
things which is very cool and then
there's all this scatter and a lot of
that scatter is tropical plants and so
that tells us that not only is this
operating this species richness this
number of species in a given location is
operating on the creating more genetic
diversity but
also potentially creating or associated
with more shape diversity or ecological
diversity so how does morphological
shape space evolved according to
latitude or vary according to latitude I
think this is kind of the first step at
really accessing this one of these
projections we could kind of create a
way to redo this process and look more
deeply at it statistically but
essentially there are some kind of
unique variations and the next step is
to is to kind of combine that with our
analysis of the species and numbers and
so that's what we're working on now
so with that many contributors to this
we've heard about this botany
digitization project I think a number of
times you know huge thanks to the
efforts that are not going not only
going into digitizing the botany
collection that's happening at Peabody
many other natural history museums
around the world but the efforts to
digitize these collections are really
the only way that we can perform an
analysis at this scale so thanks very
much
[Applause]
[Music]